oh my God the liquid volume
I was always looking at everything in
wonder
it's like what is this if we'd done this
on wires it would look hokey if we tried
to do this any other way instead of
being legit it wouldn't be a James
Cameron film the underwater performance
capture first of all it's a huge amount
to think about
the physical challenge of holding your
breath there's then the added challenge
of acting out a scene underwater where
everything is very different you're
having to imagine coral reefs you're
having to picture other not the swimming
around you then you have the challenge
of your movements are very very
different underwater finding that
Serenity in that calm so there's all of
that to take care of and that's what
you're after just the truthful sensation
and that truth is what you need to make
these movies work
what Jim wanted to do is give the actors
an environment that was going to be as
realistic as possible build set and give
them the ability to swim through the
water and give it waves and current and
everything we had Decks that had this
Unistrut system built that were on
gantries and chain Motors so that we
could lift them up and build the set on
top of it above the water and then lower
them back down once the set was built
that system has the ability to also tilt
those platforms and a lot of times we
will need that relationship with
interacted topography